John schaffner designed the most famous
New York City apartment of all time
except it only had three walls and no
ceiling and it wasn't actually in New
York john shafte designed a set of
friends John is a production designer
and John has worked on a lot of show
I've done 44 series and sixty eight
pilots dharman Greg The Drew Carey Show
two and a Half Men Big Bang Theory and
most notably friends
when I get assigned a new show I do what
is called a sketch model in white paper
and you hold it up and you close one eye
and you squint and you can see just what
the camera is gonna see when we were
presenting friends I presented a white
model and the producer ik looked at it
and said well now what are we gonna do
about color what do you want to do and I
said I think we should paint the sad
purple everybody was really anxious
about nobody likes change until I
painted the little model purple color is
really important in terms of
establishing the show identity when you
switch to friends you saw that it was
purple and you stay tuned
one of the responsibilities of a
production designer is to look into the
future if you can we put a door all the
way up this hallway and we really didn't
say where it went to I said why don't we
just wait and see where the story is
taken so all of a sudden years into the
show we've never seen this door open
they do an entire episode about this was
Monica's messy closet oh my god I
definitely think that the coffee house
on Friends sort of influenced our
culture where people like to meet and
hang around thank you and now of course
25 years later there's the coffee house
on every corner I'm surprised how many
of them have overstuffed chairs
why don't you do in the pilot at the
moment when Rachel walks through the
door and the wedding dress is a pivotal
moment we made a decision to put the
door up here on a diagonal
she bucks POW through those doors and
straight to the camera and everybody had
to like physically turn and look this is
everybody this is Chandler and Phoebe
and Joey and you remember my brother
Ross
who knew that that was going to be the
beginning of ten years of a number one
show on television audiences relate to
sitcoms because once you get to know the
characters you become invested in their
story so it's easy to turn on and watch
an episode of friends it's a comfort
coming back to visit with these
characters and be with them for that
half-hour I'm so lucky I got to design
friends
[Music]